there's no more makeup now you're done
ain't no point when you're masked up
there's no more makeup masks on and
we're gonna be so [ __ ] excited to see
one another we're not gonna care if you
have extra long curly eyebrows oh yeah
well [ __ ] mascara or any of that [ __ ]
we're not gonna care but this is a
girl's opportunity as soon as they get
soon as we're allowed outside they're
all gonna get dolled up they've been
waiting they have they're waiting
they're well they're good but we don't
have to feed into that we don't have to
recreate that on our end as guys I know
no one [ __ ] crunches all the whole
time ER in quarantine no we're gonna
look like [ __ ] coming out but I guess
what I'm saying girls it's like we were
[ __ ] Hungry Hungry Hippos but we are
ready to go yeah literally you could
walk outside in the exact same thing
you've been wearing the entire
quarantine we're gonna take it 109 we're
starved for it you don't gotta do you
think post quarantine the the [ __ ]
levees will open do girls want to get
[ __ ] like will it be wild if you're a
single guy right now
hundred percent I think games gonna be
new level new level but I also think
women are gonna understand the
importance of relationship like those
girls they're just like I'm gonna fall
over and like I'm gonna be a [ __ ] on
being a [ __ ] is fun and all that kind
of [ __ ] like you can do that when
society is great and money's green and
your jobs guaranteed and are like free
sex and frivolousness sexually yeah we
for is luxury yeah like all these hoes
are bored out their mind now what's
Weezy doing bored
nothing chillin nice you might be in
Mexico assumption but if not like all
these girls who were like single but
they were hoeing yeah they're bored out
their [ __ ] mind right now
yeah whole life only works in the first
world in luxury if you got any sort of
struggle whatsoever like if a hurricane
comes and tears apart your [ __ ] a
house every year you can want a man to
help you put that [ __ ] back together
ain't no hos in the [ __ ] Caribbean yo
yo relationships are great in crisis
time back and most people live in crisis
yeah you're right like all these
feminists mad quiet now huh oh you write
real quiet all these [ __ ] proud they
can't cook where you at now
you know I mean besides being a nuisance
to your [ __ ] man your man is finding
out exactly how useful you are with [ __ ]
hits the fan yeah
you know I'm an uber and that's true
this is most of human history is just
struggle and trying to survive
that's why monogamy some was important
back in the day how you survived it's
how the kids survived yeah hey bro Tech
this kid a bro you got multiple families
that [ __ ] from different women that
might be hard to handle yeah you can
only rebuild one house at a time no rap
right if you got multiple families in
quarantine
it's a wrap Sun shelter at home we tone
wits home you better no [ __ ] in their
pants right now
[ __ ] I for real I think we might come
out of this little different bro people
Mike women might get like a reality
check out of this there might be like
whoa this whole life is not for me whoa
it is free sex [ __ ] oh that that's only
works when things are good oh it
absolutely sucks
oh I understand the value of monogamy
hmm you want to have someone even if
that someone isn't the person you're
gonna marry it's nice to have someone
right now yourself out isolated years
ago you built this hey hey man we need
it call a hoe we need to call her and
see if she's if she wants to be too
redeemed bra if she's done with this
life go and do a whole food shop alone
Tuco for nobody
yo fighting off [ __ ] Anna to the
grocery store alone hey hey you're not
going through your toilet paper is just
you know comes in you order in from
sugar fish a couple times that's
exciting eventually you just eat your
sugar fish alone whoo come on now y'all
yeah come on now did you already talk
about how all the sugar daddies are
gonna die from Corona oh [ __ ] so now
they're sugar daddies are dead now you
got now you just sugar huh you know
these IG thoughts they gonna be taking a
lot of domestic pictures all of a sudden
son yeah here's Cincinnati you literally
we got a great zoo you are you are flew
doubt yeah
all these [ __ ] are flute you're not
you're not getting flew out yeah no
doubt of your lifestyle bro yeah it's a
rap for you OHS it's so true it's over
the gig is up these hoes gonna be taking
pictures with baby tigers and the tiger
behind a cage and it is geotag zoo San
Diego Zoo that's it bro oh man it's
gonna be hard out here we gotta call
some hoes and ask how they're coping
through this [ __ ] man because it's
lonely in these streets a lot of face
time you know you can't FaceTime that
married guy you were [ __ ] he's with
his wife who knows how to cook he
ignoring you he dilip I block your
father by now blot anyway man prayers
out to you hoes man hopefully you change
your life and realize the value of uh
you know being with a man and and
cooking for him and looking after him
and nurtured him and loving somebody and
loved it on some math yourself besides
yourself man that is what you're here
for
literally what you are put on this
planet to do what you've evolved to do
for millions of years all those things
so you might might Oh realize why you
know am i real and matter-of-fact maybe
take this time learn how to do all those
shits that you should all you lonely
feminists out there take this time to
learn how to be a woman again it might
be hard for some of you why
well now their hair just growing out you
know you got a little short ass haircut
like me let that [ __ ] grow out be a
woman again that's all kovat is doing
it's just letting the feminist March
[ __ ] learn all that pink hair grow
out what you're watching [ __ ] you can't
go nowhere exactly - in the kitchen
[ __ ]
bare minimum bakes eggs [ __ ] start with
one meal you gonna take a bacon Hey yeah
the least you could do you got time on
your hands get your life right now get
you a man to bring home the bacon then
you cook that [ __ ] let's go
[Music]